breaking news the federal reserve just
announced a 75 basis point hike all that
means is that they are trying to make
the cost of capital more expensive
simultaneous to them continuing to
increase interest rates they're also
conducting quantitative tightening
they're offloading assets off their
balance sheet why are they doing this
they're doing it because we have 8.6
percent inflation a 40-year high in the
united states if the central bank
doesn't step in they feel like inflation
will only continue to persist and
accelerate higher now whether you think
they're right or they're wrong it's
pretty clear that the federal reserve
they want to re-establish their
credibility they want people to think
that they're in control and if they see
high inflation they believe that they
can go ahead and manipulate interest
rates and conduct quantitative
tightening in order to get that
inflation come down now of course as
they're doing this and they're focused
on inflation they're crashing asset
prices at the same time we've seen
things like bitcoin the crypto market
saw 70 to 90 percent stocks are down
materially so our bonds real estate many
other asset classes quite literally the
federal reserve is crashing asset
markets in an attempt to tame inflation
now what becomes really fascinating
about this is that even as they're
increasing interest rates they don't
have that much of a runway ultimately if
they continue to increase interest rates
they're going to push the united states
into a recession given that we're in a
midterm election year the worst thing
that they could have is go into an
election season in a recession the
second worst thing is high inflation and
right now it looks like we're gonna keep
having persistently high inflation the
federal reserve thinks it'll be five
percent still by the end of the year and
also they may push us into a recession
hello stagflation now of course i don't
know what's gonna happen in the future
but what i do think is that the market
is drastically overestimating how
confident and persistent the fed's going
to be in these interest rate hikes and
in quantitative tightening i think that
at some point before the market realizes
it the federal reserve's going to give
up they're going to wave that white flag
they simply cannot continue to increase
the price of capital and they cannot
continue to conduct quantitative
tightening forever they also can't do it
for the next two to three years as they
continue to say the federal reserve can
only continue to increase interest rates
so much if they continue on this path
and they don't let up there's a lot of
people that are going to walk into that
voting booth in november and they're
gonna vote out every single person that
appointed these officials ultimately
what we are watching right now is that
the federal reserve they're in control
every asset correlation is going towards
one it all has become one big trade but
at the end of the day the federal
reserve they're gonna have to cut rates
they're gonna have to return to loose
monetary policy the big question in
financial markets right now is when are
they gonna do it 75 basis points that's
a big boy rate hike today but i don't
think this is going to become the norm i
actually think they're going to give up
way before most other people think so